Democratic Senator Joe Manchin of West
Virginia is with us from Capitol Hill
senator good morning let's start John to
you and Gail Nora good to see you after
the President's speech last night will
it be easier or harder to work with the
president for Democrats I can't speak
for the rest of my caucus I really can
do you know we're all Americans whether
you're democrat or republican you got to
make make this place work and you got to
reach across the aisle hi out of respect
and civility I thought you know I showed
the respect for the president a lot of
the things he said I liked we've got to
try to make it happen and like I say I
had a look at the details now and how we
can fix infrastructure how we can attack
the opiate addiction and how we can get
pensions back to miners how I can get
their pensions paid for this so much we
need to do John and you know just to sit
there and frowns not going to fix
anything so let's let's embrace each
other and try to make it work and what
we disagree we can work through that and
that's what I'm trying to do you you
talking to your own party there yeah I
do I do I I speak up and they've been
very courteous to me I don't have a
whole lot that come from the same
demographics that I come from or believe
may be the same as I I'm writing in the
middle of John I can you know I try to
find the best on both sides and I
probably vote in the middle more than
anybody else but you know I just said if
I can go home and explain it I can vote
for it if I can't explain it to West
Virginia then it's something I shouldn't
vote for senator that could win
bipartisan support well I really think
in the infrastructure my goodness I've
never seen a pothole that wasn't
belonging to the Democrat Republican I
thought the potholes was all of our
responsibility so infrastructure just
basic infrastructure rural
electrification rural broadband
high-speed all the things that we need
to reinvigorate our economy and I've
said this to the president I said you
know the stock market's doing great
everyone's boasting about the economy I
want West Virginia to have the same
opportunities and that means
diversifying our economy and working
with us so I'm going to embrace
everything I can to make it better for
my state what I think that's good we can
do that he raised eyebrows a couple of
times last night one in particular when
he called on Congress to empower every
cabinet secretary with the authority to
reward good
workers and to remove federal employees
who undermine the public trust or failed
the American people how did that land
with you well let me tell you when I was
governor I know where he's coming from
because he's used to the private sector
with bonuses and incentives that really
reward people for good for their good
work outstanding outstanding services
but it's hard in public service so what
I always said
give me the budget for my agency at the
end of the year if my agency has
performed up and beyond and let's say I
had X amount of dollars left and I have
40 people in one agency or a hundred
people then divide that and give them
basically some incentive and rewards for
what they have done to follow on Gail's
point I think some are concerned that
that suggestion that that cabinet
secretaries can do whatever they want
might apply to the FBI and the Justice
Department no not absolutely not you
know there's three branches of
government for this great democracy and
we're the greatest democracy on earth
okay and with the greatest history with
that it's because the rule all and three
branches of equal equal stature and
we're going to exercise that we're going
to protect that vigorously things that I
agree on and things that I would say mr.
president
trust your judicial system trust the
system that we have believe in these
people here let the system work its will
and it'll be fine standard you're on the
Intelligence Committee had a chance to
look at the work the FBI has done is it
tainted is it crooked or is it straight
up I have the utmost respect I have been
able to work with these people in
intelligence community FBI CIA on down
and if anyone would just take time to
meet with a dedicated people we have
they don't do it for fame or fortune
John they sure don't they do it because
of the love and patriotism they have for
our country and they are the best of the
best the Republicans on the House
Intelligence Committee have voted to
release the núñez memo the president
told a member of Congress last night
100% he's going to release it despite
the fact that the FBI and the Justice
Department have urged
not to would you say that the president
is wrong to release that memo
I was definitely saying mr. president
please not do that that is wrong it is
absolutely wrong
first of all people even reveal his
sources Devon Nunez okay this is a man
that was sanctioned by his own committee
members that he couldn't be on the
Russian probe this is a person basically
this kind of shoots from the hip and I
said he is Nunez has neutered the
credibility of this Intelligence
Committee on the house the Senate
Intelligence Committee is the only thing
that we have left that can put
confidence into the system and also into
the investigation what he is doing is
just wrong just throwing caution to the
wind and trying to trash the whole
judicial system is absolutely so wrong
and irresponsible any member of the
intelligence committee knows better than
that
the president appears to be doing a bit
of a mood walk when it comes to talking
to Special Counsel Moeller first he said
I look forward to talking to him now he
says if my lawyers allow it and now it
seems well he might not talk to him at
all what do you say about that and
there's still possibility speculation
that he may try to fire Special Counsel
Mulder what do you say about that well
first of all let's talk about defying a
molar I pray to God that doesn't happen
for the sake of our country and I and I
would say from the presidency and his
and and and his administration that
would be the absolutely wrong thing I
think what you'll do then you will see
Congress Cochise
around this system basically to protect
protect the judicial system and protect
mr. Muller I really believe that so I
believe that would be a wrong move and
also watch and see if they move on
Rosenstein first because that's the
chain of events that would happen let me
tell you my recommendation let this play
out let us finish this investigation let
mr. Maule or do this thing and the facts
you know the facts and the truth will
set you free
senator Manchin always good to have you
thank you so much I know or thank you
John and Gail thank you so much thank
you for taking the time uh-huh thank you
that boy